I first started doing television weather
in 1974 when I was a sophomore in college,
and I have seen a lot of changes
that I know you have.
From history-making hurricanes,
we're talking about
record-breaking blizzards.
I've been --
(Laughter)
Yeah, OK, laugh at my suffering.
I'm glad you feel that good.
Hurricane Sandy, this was really,
to me, a game changer as far as climate,
when people realized what was going on.
Hurricane Ida, which came onshore,
causing massive problems
not just at landfall
but also as it moved inland
causing massive, massive flooding.
A lot of us recently experienced
dangerous air quality
because of wildfires up in Canada,
that smoke stretched
as far south as Atlanta.
We're also experiencing
atmospheric rivers,
cyclogenic bombs of low pressure.
We’ve also looked at rising
ocean levels and, of course,
paralyzing winter storms,
stretching from Texas into the northeast,
unprecedented heat and flash flooding
all within the last couple of weeks.
If we were to talk
about everything that's going on,
all these extreme weather events
that have been happening
in the last couple of years,
we would literally be here
for a couple of hours.
So we just wanted to take a look
at some of the extreme weather events
that are being fueled by climate change.
So we boiled it down
to a few key bullet points,
talking about hurricanes,
tornadoes and wildfires.
And literally this is the tip
of the iceberg
when it comes to climate change.
Let's talk about, for example, hurricanes.
Did you know that between 2016 and 2019,
we had four straight years
with Category 5 hurricanes?
That's the top of the level.
That is unprecedented.
And beyond the increasing frequency,
hurricanes are also
intensifying more rapidly.
We're seeing that happen time
and time again with these hurricanes
as they approach shore.
And this is because
the environment is favorable,
because the ocean waters have heated up.
Now, let's talk about tornadoes.
Same thing goes for this.
Studies have shown an increase
in tornado frequency,
more EF2 tornadoes in the Midwest
and the Southeast.
There's actually been
a diminution of those tornadoes
in the traditional tornado belt.
They have moved east, south and north
in areas that are a lot more prevalent
with larger populations.
And we're talking about more
tornadoes during winter,
which is really something that we
haven't seen in the last ten years.
Wildfires.
OK, we know about the wildfires
that happen out West,
and the average acreage burned
in warm season has nearly doubled.
There is no more wildfire season out West.
And the folks out West were laughing
at us in the East saying,
"Hey, get used to it.
This is what we've been seeing."
We're getting used to bad air quality.
And in fact, the intensity
from these frequent wildfires
has led to the deterioration
of our lifestyle, our air quality,
loss of property and crops.
It is just really one of these things
that is changing how we live.
But what happens to those folks
who actually struggle?
Struggle with the actual
impacts of climate change?
Now, we've known for years
that communities
that are most vulnerable
to the effects of climate change
are the ones that are least responsible
for climate change itself.
In fact, the most recent Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change,
the IPCC,
estimates that in the next 30 years,
and that's not that long,
140 million people
will be displaced worldwide.
That's more than the population of Russia.
That's how many people
we're talking about.
Here in the United States,
federal government has had to start
to compensate Indigenous communities
because they've had to move
because of sea level rise
and warming of the atmosphere.
We were recently in Alaska
and saw the change
that has happened to the Indigenous
communities there
because of their lifestyle,
their community and their heritage
is being lost because of this.
Now about 75 percent of the world
lives under the poverty line
in rural areas.
And these are the same areas
whose natural resources
are being undermined and destroyed
by extreme drought,
torrential rainfall and wildfires.
And even though they try
to do what they can,
these events often force these communities
from their very homes,
changing their lives,
their communities and their culture.
Now, outside of our cultural communities,
climate change has an effect
on our national security.
And that change of climate
is going to affect
the ability to train war fighters,
to maintain facilities at home and abroad
and to be able to operate effectively
with a fighting force
because of climate change.
And in fact, a recent report
by the Rand Corporation
highlighted how climate change
is already affecting military sites
all around the world
because of the diversion of funds
to have to harden these sites
against climate change.
And you think about vulnerability,
one of the things we have to think about,
the people who work outside,
in one of the earlier sessions,
we had some farmers here
talking about this.
Well, farmers, farm workers,
outdoor industries, construction workers,
even our kids at summer camps,
they have to change how they work
because of hotter and hotter summers.
Now what can we do?
How do we change things?
How do we get those solutions going
that help us harden ourselves
against climate change?
Well, one of the most impactful
options is electrification.
Sure, we think about cars,
but what about stoves?
What about lawnmowers, leaf blowers?
In fact, a recent automotive test --
think about this, running
a leaf blower for 30 minutes
adds more pollution to the atmosphere
than an F-150 truck driving 3,800 miles.
(Audience) Whoa!
One leaf blower.
And not to mention the noise.
You change over
to an electric leaf blower ...
OK --
(Applause)
I'm not sure if you're against
electric or leaf blowers,
but you should be for both.
And of course,
everybody will appreciate it,
not only your neighbors,
but your animal neighbors as well.
And in fact, when we talk about our lawns,
because a lot of lawn care goes into this,
we need to stop thinking about,
you know, that green, lush lawn.
Let's rethink that to using
more shrubbery, more brushes,
more drought-resistant plants.
It’s called xeriscaping.
So that there’s less green
as far as lawns, well-manicured lawns,
and more natural, indigenous plants
that help conserve water
and help the actual planet
keep that water in.
And then there's another area
that we can talk about.
I know you look at me and you think,
"Yes, he's fashionable.
Yes, he's GQ."
Right? OK.
Well, the fact of the matter is,
you know, fast fashion,
that is just a real detriment
for our environment.
It's cheap, quick, mass-produced fashions
that are meant to be discarded,
fill up our landfills, cause pollution
because of the dyes that are used.
So what you end up doing
is adding to landfills
and spending a lot of money.
Instead, find good, durable,
sustainable clothing
that's going to last more than one season
and you help reduce our landfills
and causing more problems.
And look good doing it, too.
(Laughter)
And lastly, the most important thing.
Engagement.
You have to be engaged.
You have to know,
let your elected officials know
that this is important to you.
You have to vote.
You have to go out there
and support politicians
who are going to support our planet.
You know, one of the things
that has changed my outlook
in a very short period of time.
Nine days ago, I became a grandpa.
(Cheers and applause)
I thought you’d pause and think,
“He’s not old enough.”
But.
Obviously that's not the case.
But I was holding my new granddaughter,
Sky, which is -- I love the name.
Aww.
And I was literally, on Tuesday,
sitting about two hours, holding her,
while I let my daughter
and her husband get a break.
And I was thinking about giving this talk.
And I was thinking about,
what kind of world is she going to have?
I mean, let's face it.
I'm only going to be here, if I'm lucky,
maybe another 15 years.
Who knows?
But it's her world.
All of our grandkids and their kids,
it's going to be their world.
What world are we leaving them?
This younger generation
is going to fight this fight.
So support them.
Support politicians who decide
that our planet and its health
is the more important thing,
that climate change is the most
existential threat to our survival.
And make sure that you do what you can.
Be conscious of the decisions you make.
We can all get together
and make each individually come together
and make a great change
and change our planet.
Thank you very much.
(Cheers and applause)